hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
elispot assay which is an immunoassay
used to determine number of cells which
are secreting
cytokines now this elispot assay
captures the presence of a cytokine
producing
cell in a patient sample let's say
plasma or serum
now the assay is very simple and easy to
perform
so that is why it is preferable for the
medical individuals
as a diagnostic tool the elixir assay
is not limited for cytokines but also
it can be suitable for determining other
type of cells secreting certain kind of
proteins
and lastly assay was actually discovered
to quantify immunoglobulin producing
cells
so let us look at what is the bits and
pieces and what is the principle behind
ali spot assay so ali spot assay is not
similar to eliza
so eliza and ali spot assay has
something in common
which is the antigen antibody
interaction
now eliza detects antigen or antibody in
a patient serum sample or a plasma
sample
now you can understand that ali spot
assay determines
cytokine secreting cell types present in
a patient's sample
so this is the major difference between
elisa and the ali spot assay
however elispot assay is kind of a
modified elisa so we need to understand
the principle of elisa before we go to
elispot assay
so here is how eliza works this is a
basic framework
using elisa you can determine many thing
in this case we are going to look at
how we can detect an antibody present in
a patient sample
so first of all we want to check some
antigen
we have to coat our wells of microtiter
plate with a certain antigen
then we have to add patient sample which
would probably have the antibody
then if the antibody is present then
after adding secondary antibodies
it would bind to the end of primary
antibody and the secondary antibody is
enzyme linked
so a chromogenic reaction would take
place and with the development of color
the absorbance value would change
looking at the absorbance value the
concentration of these antibodies
can be calculated so this is how we can
get a quantitative overview
in terms of presence of a antibody
in a sample now let us talk about
elispot assay and how it is exactly
performed in the lab
so here is a microtiter plate and we are
looking at one particular whale of the
microtiter plate to understand the
phenomena better so the first step is
coating
the wells with antibodies against the
cytokine to be determined
so let us understand that we want to
determine a particular cytokine and we
have the antibody against it so we would
coat the well with antibody
like shown here then we would add the
patient sample
in that well now after adding the
patient sample
which would have the cells
secreting cytokines they would
eventually
bind with the antibodies right the
cytokines which are secreted by the cell
would be binding with the antibodies
then a wash tape would wash away all
those unnecessary things
and ultimately what we would get after
the wash tip
is only the cytokines bound with them
with that particular antibodies which
are coating the well
now step four is to add secondary
antibodies which are
enzyme linked after adding secondary
antibodies which are enzyme linked
another wash tip is performed to remove
the unbound substances
then these secondary antibodies which
are linked with
enzyme can ultimately evoke a
chromogenic
reaction as they are bound with these
antigens that is why we would see
specific
spot in a microtiter plate and each of
this spot
is indicative of a particular cell that
is secreting that particular cytokine
we can simply understand it in this way
that number of cells
is kind of proportional to the number of
spots present in the well so the spot
number actually determines the cell
density
let us take an example where there are
two individual one is candida infected
and
one is candida not infected and we want
to understand that whether
th 17 cells are produced or not and we
know th17 produce
il22 antibody il22 cytokine
so we need to do a il22 elispot assay
in this case the wells would be coated
with il-22
and the il-22 antibody and
we would detect the presence of il-22 in
the sample
now it has been seen in from this result
the candida infected
individual and his serum has a hell lot
of spots
developed in ali spot assay that means
his syrup
indeed has cells which are
producing il-22 cytokines
now we can also use this to determine
viral titers for example
in case of viral infections we have
th1 production production th1 some type
of t cell production
this th one type of cells are actually
inflammatory
so in order to understand the presence
of th1 sample th1 cells
in a patient sample who was infected by
a virus we can perform
several acids one is elispot acid so we
can
perform ifn gamma elispot assay because
we know that th1 cells whenever it is
produced they secretes ifn gamma or
interferon gamma
so detecting the presence of interferon
gamma would indirectly tell us about the
presence of
th1 cell so that is why whenever we do
the alispot assay if we see spots that
means
that patient that patient was infected
by the virus and now
th1 cells are produced as an immune
response so type of
immune response which type of cells are
produced in the immune response
if you want to analyze these kind of
questions elispot assay is one of the
best acid
now overall we can also compare that how
much an individual is
in how much the individual has started
an immune response against a viral
infection so here are two individuals we
can see the individual on the left hand
side
has more spots in the elispot assay that
means
strong immune response has been
generated in person one
compared to person two and that is why
we see more cytokine producing th
one type of cells in this example so
these kind of comparative analysis can
also be done
using elispot asset data so just to
summarize
the advantages of elispot assay that
single cell versus bulk analysis can be
done
individual cell variation is
biologically important and that can be
done
here elispot assay is extremely
extremely sensitive so you really
need very less amount of sample which is
important in a clinical setting now
elispot assay also allows a quantitative
measurement that is very important
elispot acid also reduce the sample
necessity that means in in case many
cases we don't get that much of sample
but as this assay is very sensitive so
it
i mean it doesn't require a whole lot of
sample so those are the advantages
of elispot assay and by the way elispot
assay is also cost effective and widely
used in the medical community for
these kind of purposes and specially
this is preferred by the immunologist to
determine what type of cells
are present when a particular type of
immune response is
augmented so i hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up and don't forget to like
share and subscribe thank you